- Hey guys, how is it going?
It's Justine and this is my sister Jenna.
- Hello.
- Happy Easter.
These ears were complement of
Jenna, she brought them out.
She's like, "Is this an Easter video?"
I said,--
- They're really soft.
- Yes, it is, they are very soft.
- After this I think the dog wants them.
He keeps trying to get the off of our head
- He's really into them.
- He is.
- But today we are playing this game.
I went on the Amazon, I
searched for Easter Game.
(laughs) and this is what showed up.
- That must've taken you all day.
(laughing)
- You're so funny.
So this game is called
Jumping Jack and you basically
well, the little bit
of research that I did,
you pull carrots out of the ground
and then you have to catch the rabbit.
So whoever catches the rabbit
when he jumps out of the ground wins.
- This is gonna be super
competitive, I'm in.
- Great, let's open it up.
- Jumping Jack, Jumping Jack.
Jumping Just.
- What are the ages on here?
- Probably, two--
- Four plus,
- two to four.
- No, that's how many people can play it.
- Oh, four plus.
- Choking hazard.
Do not put the pieces in your mouth.
- Don't tell me what to do, lady.
- Oh here's Jack.
- Oh my goodness, this little Jack.
I'm surprised he's not in a box.
- He was, I just took him out.
All right.
- Oh, he's squishy.
- Okay cause he like
jumps out of here, you
don't want to get hurt.
So here's the thing, you have
to catch him in a basket.
- Okay, hope it doesn't
actually change anything,
cause I don't know.
Oh my goodness
- Oh what happened?
The first step is to plant
the carrots in the bunny hill.
- On it.
- By pushing one carrot
in each hole until you hear a click.
- Rapid carrot pushing.
Do these fly out?
- No, this is the basket so
pick which color you want.
I'd like the purple, it matches my ears.
- Guess I'll do this.
But then there's no contrast.
- True, you do what you want.
So, number two, we place
Jack on his bunny hill
by pushing him into the post
in the center of the hill.
He can't--
- Oh.
- We gotta jam him in here.
- Should we wear safety glasses?
- No, that's why he's soft.
- He's not that soft.
- He's soft.
- He's like medium
- Don't touch Jack.
He's busy right now.
Put the spinner where all
players can reach it, okay.
- Well,
- Here we go.
So we spin the wheel, so
each player is removing
how ever many carrots is on here.
The youngest player, oh freaking,
always the youngest player are the first.
- Do you need an adult to read?
- I'm just seeing if, do we
catch Jack in the basket.
- Do we both put the
carrots in the basket?
- We put the carrots in the basket.
- Why would we catch him in the basket?
- I'm not sure, yeah you
put it in your basket.
Okay, let's, youngest player goes first.
- Well I don't know
what these things mean,
what's the X means?
- That means you don't
get to pick a carrot.
Okay you pick two carrots.
- You pick two carrots.
- You spun the wheel.
- Put your hand on the table, lady.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Reflexes like a mother.
- I can't believe.
That was so fast.
- So now what do I,
I win.
- That was so stupid.
- I,
- [Man] All right, cut.
- All right, thank you guys
so much for watching me.
You should check out Jenna's
channel, that's me, the winner.
- Let's play again, my turn.
- Okay.
Tallying up, one, zero.
But it's on the line.
- You get to pick three.
- No.
- So what's this stupid basket for?
- That's where you put your carrots.
Okay two carrots, ready?
One carrot.
- This is really, just
- Two carrots.
- (gasps)
What's that mean?
- That means you don't get,
nothing, cause I was supposed
to take one of your carrots.
- But then why wouldn't I want to go?
Because I wouldn't want
to be able to catch him?
I'm super confused.
- It's for four year olds.
How are you--?
That's one.
Oh jeez, I am, you're so fast.
- I'm a freak.
- (singing) You're a
freaking and now you can move
no, it's a thief.
Okay, anyway, let's go.
You're so fast.
- It's why I'm better at driving.
Reflexes.
- Okay.
- Two, zero.
- How is this happening?
All right, I'm gonna go
again cause I'm a loser.
- Well now you're just blocking Jack.
Could parents to remind
you not to lean over Jack.
- I can't spin this stupid thing.
Two carrots.
- Go.
- You're blocking Jack.
Two carrots.
Shit, I don't understand.
What are you, how is this happening?
- You just kind of like, react.
Here.
(laughing)
Well.
- All right.
Can we just practice?
Can you just throw it in
the air for me real quick?
No, you, oh, okay, see, I can catch.
All right, how,
- But you knew it was coming.
- Put the hand down.
That's why you're winning,
you piece of crap.
- You're a piece of crap.
This game is really.
I hope you didn't spend
too much money on it.
- Two carrots.
- (laughing)
- I will say I'm actually
enjoying this a lot--
- Sure.
- This is gonna be
a great party game, oh guess what?
That's my carrot now.
- Why?
- Cause there was a thief and a knight.
- (laughing) sure.
False start.
- (laughing) your turn.
- I thought that, your little basket.
- My basket is so full.
- Well, but--
- Jam it in there.
- How does it.
I'm super confused, what does that mean?
- That means there was a thief
and they came and eat your carrot.
- I've got no
carrot, what?
What am I doing wrong?
Oh my basket.
- Son of a freaking, dumb, stupid rabbit.
Wait, do I win because
I have a lot of carrots?
- [Man] Unless you drop the Jack.
- Look at Jack's tongue, he's like
- Okay, we're playing this
again, I'm getting very mad,
I'm getting very mad,
this is a children's game
and I can't even catch the freaking rabbit
cause I have a stupid hole.
- Really jam it in there.
- No, you're supposed to jam it in
after you have all the things.
Okay, Jack.
- Do you want to play,
like, hands behind my back?
- No,
- Do you--?
- One carrot, I had so many
carrots, I should've won.
Your spin.
This--
- High action game.
- Oh,
- Give me that.
- This spinner is trash.
(laughing)
- You're really on edge over there.
- I'm--
- I can like sense it.
- I'm so amped up.
That's one.
- I am like twitching.
I'm gonna have nightmares
about Jack, jumping and like
- Okay, next.
- Okay.
I spun it.
- Yeah, so I take one of yours, you dummy.
- (laughing) Oh okay, well you can catch
a rabbit for a child, you.
- This spinner--
- It's going the wrong way.
It can't just spin into you like--
- Yeah but it's not spinning.
You weren't, ow.
Put those--
- You.
- Put those pointers down.
- Put your pointer down.
(laughing)
You didn't try.
- Yes, I did.
I did.
- Your hand didn't even move.
Can you rewind in slo-mo,
like, she's not moving.
- My reflexes aren't actually,
It doesn't make sense, it
doesn't make sense to me.
Why I can't freaking catch this stupid,
let's, let's just try,
can we just, can we just,
okay--
- Do you want to play by yourself?
- Yeah, let's jam all
these carrots in there.
And I just want you to take them out
and I want to be able to catch this one.
Just let me catch this one.
- Is it competitive?
- No.
This is just, this is like,
this is one of those things
where your child is really
not good at things, and you
try to make them feel better.
- So go ahead.
Okay, here, ready?
Maybe you do it, you pull.
- No, you take them out and
I just need to be ready.
- We should time it.
Put your hands on the counter.
- Oh it doesn't really matter, okay.
Oh I got it.
What are you doing now?
- We're gonna compete.
- What are we competing for?
- Who can catch him.
This is so fun.
Here, it's okay Just, to be fair, I--
- You have to put the carrots in first.
- I just had caffeine,
so I'm all amped up.
Like super ready to catch Jack.
- My turn, I'm gonna catch him.
- Are we competing?
- Oh my God, I quit, I quit,
I don't want to play this game anymore,
I don't want, I am repetitively losing.
So here's the thing, I win
all the DIY challenges,
- This is where I shine, my reflexes.
Look at me, I'm super quick,
- So, wow
- Here.
Well, I think you're scared,
that's the part where you like
- That's a problem.
Well this is actually pretty fun.
Usually, I sometimes
whenever I play this game,
I'll end up just donating these,
but I'm going to keep this one
because this is a fun party game.
- We'll throw us a party with our friends.
- We will, definitely.
My adult friends.
- Okay, I'll beat them too.
- Well thank you guys
so much for watching.
Happy Easter, if you guys
have any other suggestions
for some fun games similar
to this or maybe even
a little bit more adult is fine with me.
- Clearly that's not gonna work.
- It's not gonna happen,
actually we need lower level.
- We need two, four, four plus.
- I need infants games.
This in incredible, I
don't, this is so so dumb.
I'm so upset right now,
even Maddie's upset.
- I think my favorite thing is
how you thought we were
supposed to catch with that.
- I thought we were.
- How would we catch him in the basket?
I'll put the carrot in first.
(dog barking)
- That's hard.
Okay, I'm gonna go and see
what's the dog's barking about.
- He's upset.
- I'll see in our next video, bye.
- You got to put the carrots in first.
- You're right.
Don't, I'm so upset about this game.
- You got one.
- [Man] Do I cut?
- Yeah.